I am not referring to the absolute, infinite concept of universal peace and goodwill...
...of which some fantasies and fanatics dream.
Let us focus instead on a more practical, more attainable peace.
This will require a new effort, a new context for world discussions.
It will require increased understanding...
...and increased understanding will require increased contact.
So let us not be blind to our differences...
...but let us also direct attention to our common interests.
Our most basic common link is that we all inhabit this small planet.
We all breathe the same air.
We all cherish our children's future.
And we are all mortal.